let's turn to some other breaking news
at this hour and the last step our also
president Turkish president vegetarian
has announced the start of Turkish
military action in northern Syria
Turkish TV reports that Jets are
carrying out airstrikes on Syrian
Kurdish positions in the border town of
tal Abyad early video footage shows
strikes hitting fields but reports from
the Kurdish led Syrian democratic forces
say the airstrikes are causing huge
panic among the people before the
strikes a president Erdogan announced
the offensive in the offensive in two
tweets and it's the Turkish Armed Forces
together with the Syrian National Army
just launched Operation piece spring
against the PKK YPG and - terrorists in
northern Syria our mission is to prevent
the creation of a terror corridor across
the southern border and to bring peace
to the area operation peace spring will
neutralize terrorist threats against
Turkey and lead to the establishment of
a safe zone facilitating the return of
Syrian refugees to their homes we will
preserve Syria's territorial integrity
and liberate local communities from
terrorists let's bring in Juergen Hart
who's a foreign policy spokesman for the
conservative parties that in the German
parliament we just heard in that tweet
there that Turkey says it is preserving
its country's territorial integrity does
it have the right to do that in this way
we have huge concerns concerning that
military operation every military
operation PSL Rizk risk of a new
escalation military escalation in the
region and this might poison or might
harm the peace process is a small about
growing peace process ongoing in Geneva
was the summit of those 150 people who
should work on a new constitution for
Syria I think the Turkish government
should stop this operation and if they
are not able and willing to stop that
should concentrate on identified
terrorists among the edge of IPC as OJ's
of height us and not on civilians or on
fighters that were on the side of the
Alliance against
and I thought they need support and not
fight by not be frightened by it by
Turkey so you say Turk you should stop
this action do you expect Germany to do
anything more than talk I think from my
point of view this is also a reason to
call the ambassador's of the NATO in
Brussels though that the Turkish
government can explain why and how they
see that in line with international law
this operation
south of the Turkish border this could
be in line with international law in
case that they want only to defend
turkey against terrorism coming out of
the region and the normal government of
Syria has not a control over their
region but as it looks now it's more
than that and that would be also against
international law and I think NATO
partners should ask that question to the
Turkish government immediately okay what
else so Germany as part of NATO should
join us that effort to talk Turkey down
what should Germany be doing as a as a
sovereign country about this conflict we
also use communication contacts to the
Turkish government the German Home
Minister was there some days ago we have
this cooperation between European Union
and Turkey concerning refugees European
Union has to continue support for Turkey
concerning the refugee question but the
current situation in north of Syria on
the south of the Turkish border is more
a crucial point that potentially might
increase refugees and not calm in the
situation and this is what the concerns
we have with the current situation
Germany has a significant Turkish
population do you have any concerns that
this action will cause attention or
unrest here in the country we know from
the past that in Germany a lot of people
are supporting president ad1 but others
supporting Kurdish population in Turkey
and in the
Syria and in Iraq we have a debate among
those political groups in Germany I
think they should continue by debating
that but my my demand on them is to do
their peacefully and to discuss the
things but not taking any any action
against the other groups because in
Germany every everyone has a right to
state his his position but yet has not
right to take violent action thank you
so much for talking to us
good talking to you a Juergen Hart
foreign policy spokesman for the
conservative parties in the German
parliament thank you so let's go to a
turkey we joined that DW correspondent
to Julia Hahn in Istanbul welcome Julia
what are you hearing about the Turkish
military operation well the operation
started at 4:00 p.m. local time just
three days after US president Trump's
sudden decision to pull back US troops
from the area the decision was announced
as you mentioned by President adwin who
was at the same time the chief commander
of the Turkish Armed Forces he did not
do that as usual in a televised speech
but he did do it on on Twitter which was
interesting to me and we got news now
that Turkish warplanes have hit targets
in northern Syria targets white pg
targets targets of first Syrian Kurdish
fighters their ammunition depots sniper
positions that's according to Turkish
officials Turkish officials who also
very keen on emphasizing that this
operation follows the standards of the
international law but there is of course
some very different information in use
coming there from the Kurdish side they
are accusing the Turkish military of
hitting civilian areas they had they are
saying that has caused huge panic in the
city of talib yet for example it has
about 20,000 people who live there and
they are saying people are trying to
escape and seek
shelter and they are also reporting the
first civilian casualties there this is
very difficult for us to independently
verify but this is what this conflict is
about very conflicting information in
interpretations what's going on there on
the ground and this operation piece
spring as it's being called what is its
purpose what is a president earlier on
trying to achieve with it well it's
turkeys cert operation in northern Syria
against the Kurdish YPG militia
I mean you you've mentioned the name
they're these military operations always
have names that sound very positive
because from the Turkish point of view
this is an operation there to defend
turkeys national security against what
they call a terrorist Turkey is clearly
saying these YPG militia in Syria are
linked to the PKK a group that has waged
a decades-long insurgency here in Turkey
the conflict has killed about 40,000
people that's the estimate so now the
way the Turkish media Turkish officials
are phrasing it this is a security
operation designed to create a safe zone
for Turkey to possibly resettle about 2
million Syrian refugees in the area so
this is the way they are selling this
whole operation now so Turkey is looking
to drive out Kurdish fighters from this
area secure it and then move Syrian
refugees in yeah but but well it sounds
may be very easy as you say it but it's
a complicated and risky operation
particularly because the Kurdish
fighters said that they won't give up
the territory without a fight they have
called for a general mobilization
they're calling upon civilians to defend
the territory there and these Kurdish
fighters are experienced fighters they
have been trained and equipped by
Washington by the US and they have
battled the Islamic state for years so
they have weapons they are very
determined to
and this territory so what's going to
happen there and this is to least to say
is we are going to see a very
complicated and messy situation there
yulia Han in Istanbul thank you from
Turkey to the United States let's go to
Washington whoever joined DW
correspondent Carla like a welcome Carla
and what reaction from the White House
to Turk his action tram has been very
active on Twitter this morning and while
he hasn't said anything directly about
Turkish military action in Syria this
morning he did talk about how he thinks
that sending US troops into these
endless war in the Middle East is in
general a bad idea and he said and I
quote the United States has spent a
trillion dollars fighting and policing
in the Middle East thousands of her
great soldiers have died or been badly
wounded going into the Middle East as
the worst decision ever made in the
history of our country okay so no
reaction so far to today's events not
directly no president Trump has said
that he would obliterate his work the
Turkish economy if this incursion goes
off limits do we know what off limits
means well he wisely hasn't made clear
where exactly his red line is when it
comes to for example attacks on the
Kurds what many people here believe is
that he had US interests in mind at that
off limits could refer to Turkey for
example not really making sure that
captured is fighters are are captured
and are kept away from Western countries
and from the US now the president was
subject to criticism from both sides of
the aisle when he announced that he was
withdrawing US troops from northern
Syria is there any other reaction from
from either from detractors or
supporters at this stage yes Lindsey
Graham
powerful senator on the Republican side
from South Carolina who is known as a
trump supporter has very heavily
criticized the president's decision and
he was active this morning saying that
when it comes to fighting is it's a bad
idea to outsource American national
security to countries like Turkey so he
and also a Senate Leader Mitch McConnell
have been have been very vocal and
criticizing this and also criticizing it
this morning after turkeys military
incursion in Syria on the Democratic
side
none of the heavyweights heavyweights
have yet reacted to these new to these
new military actions in northern Syria
but Chris Van Hollen the Democratic
senator is working on a bipartisan bill
together with Lindsey Graham that is
supposedly being finalized as we speak
and the goal of this bill is to to
punish turkey for attacking as Van
Hollen calls it our Syrian Kurdish
partners ok Carla Blanca in Washington
thank you